là monsieur le micro c'est là c'est non
parce que d'habitude je fais le nom au
mesdames messieurs après un déjeuner de
travail extrêmement positif avec mes
collègues de l'europe 10 6 9 nov
c'est très simple capitulons il y avait
là roberto holmes et car stand by halle
safire 4 et john rollins a fait six
autos et moi ça fait
9 un voleur avait déjà et de travail
extrêmement positif avec mes collègues
de l'europe des neuf déjeuner de travail
qui a duré plus de cinq heures et demi
et qui est d'ailleurs un des plus
réussis que nous ayons fait depuis six
ans eh bien je suis en mesure de vous
dire aujourd'hui que tous les problèmes
de l'europe qu'ils soient alimentaires
agricoles vinicole ou encore ceux du vin
sans oublier ceux des liqueurs et de ce
qu'on nomme à tort le pinard ont été
abordés tiens à redire à tous et
pessimiste qui voyait l'europe
agonisante bois remorque et bien je leur
dis et le redis elle est repartie
l'europe comme en quarts en avant dès le
problème des laitages hollandais dans le
mois lorsqu'il est bien parce qu' est-ce
que vous avez abordé le problème des
laitages l'onu oui oui ça ils ont été
évoqués durant ce déjeuner de travail et
je crois que cette fois monsieur van
houtte hervé qu'a compris la mimolette
ne passera pas moi j'ai repris 4 fois du
camembert ans le marchand avec du beurre
breton et ça ne nous a pas impressionné
outre mesure que monsieur van houtte
ehrbeck pour se venger et but avec le
ministre danois de bouteille de schnaps
qu'un la belgique violent l'allemagne et
moi même avons immédiatement répliqué en
visant neuf bouteilles de pommard
rétablissant ainsi l' équilibre vital au
sein de la communauté monsieur ministre
le problème des hormones dans la
volaille anglaise écouter alors ça va
vous dire parce que personne n'en a pris
1 lorsque le poulet au porridge est
arrivé là le monde rien que la sauce
déjà ça avait l'air pire que les
hormones nakano ministre allemand qui a
eu le courage de prendre une cuisse oui
qui dit quelque chose de ce ministre est
donc non très sincèrement il s'est
contenté de recracher en proposant que
la grande bretagne soit issu du marché
commun avez vous abordé les problèmes de
limites de pêche de mai qui les limite
de la pêche au quai pour la langoustine
monsieur nous voilà le petit écran dès
2011 les meilleurs délais avec toute
évidence un jeu gars n'avait pas emmené
je ne peux pas vous dire et la viande à
écouter alors ça je tiens à le répéter
encore une fois j'espère que ce sera la
dernière il n'y a aucun problème de
viande dans le marché commun écouter
lorsqu'on mange avec un bon appétit et
un bon côtes du rhône qui veut me dis à
la différence qu'il ya entre un mouton
anglais une vache allemande ou un fort
italien qui sinon ceux qui veulent
casser l'europe au en jouant la carte de
la différence écoutez nous étions là
neuf ministres et je vous rappelle que
nous sommes des ministres spécialistes
nous étions là neuf ministres et bien
nous avons dégusté les viandes
aucun de nous n'a pu dire ni de quel
pays il de quel animal cette viande
provenait et tout ça pourquoi parce que
nous voulons une europe égale pour tous
même pour les animaux
et pour les animaux aussi
aulas face à une très bonne proposition
du ministre luxembourgeois qui s'est
tellement régalé avec le curry d'agneau
qu'il a proposé que l'a proposé que
l'aisne
entre-temps le marché commun ce à quoi
nous avons tous dit d'accord à gauche
y'a pas longtemps à condition que l'on
supprime les crédits pour la culture des
choux de bruxelles qu'on a tous trouvé
mais qu'on a mangé quand même eu égard
et par politesse et de politesse et
d'expérience dans la ville ou dans
laquelle on se trouve à bruxelles
à bruxelles vont écouter bessieux il est
maintenant au moins
20h30 et je crois que je vais devoir
vous quitter car nous avons ce soir à
dîner de travail très important car je
vous rappelle que le très grave problème
du coupage des vins italiens et français
n'a pas encore été résolu
cela risque de nous emmener très tard
dans la nuit
on y passera le temps qu'il faudra mais
on y arrivera
monsieur milices